well the last time president biden held
a solo white house news conference was
nearly a year ago
at that lectern
democrats are hoping he can turn the
page now from the party's setbacks at
the white house reportedly considers a
new communication strategy they're going
to do a reset
president biden has given fewer than
half as many news conferences as any
modern president at their point at this
point in their term in fact president
biden's three immediate predecessors all
held double-digit news conferences by
this point in their terms
joe i'm coming to you first
well as you noted he hasn't held a solo
press conference at the white house
nearly 300 days as a dad i can tell you
that's enough to carry a baby to full
term and take a month off to enjoy the
moment but but i think this will be as
big a test well you know we got to put
in context somehow right this will be as
big a test for the white house press
corps will be for mr biden because here
you have a president at 33 approval 28
approval among hispanics just soak that
in for a second only one in four
independents support him build back
better is dead voting rights which
really should be called the
federalization and overhaul of elections
also pushing daisies so there's plenty
of discontent here that goes well beyond
conservatives and republicans so here's
what i would ask for what it's worth mr
president more than 2.3 million people
have crossed over the u.s southern
border since you took office that's
almost two and a half times the total
population of your home state of
delaware you have yet to visit the
border yet
fentanyl is coming into this country in
record numbers primarily from central
america and it is now the leading killer
of those living in this country for
those between the ages of 18 and 49 more
than covet more than suicide so what are
you doing what is your vice president
doing to address a the border crisis and
b the fentanyl crisis killing so many
relatively young americans i'd kick it
off with that and then i would leave it
here harris
sir why is it harder to vote in your
home state of delaware where you served
as a senator for many years or harder
for senate majority leader chuck
schumer's home state of new york in
terms of voting there than it is in
georgia which you have dubbed jim crow
2.0 specifically why is georgia worse
when comparing those states that's what
has to happen here we need reporters to
get specific and we need them to pass
their own test in terms of
accountability and scrutiny and i guess
we're going to find out if they pass
that test in about four hours from now
well kaylee we know that the previous
white house was given that test almost
every time you guys walked up to the
lectern but this is a president who's
rarely alone taking a lot of questions
it'll be interesting
it'll be incredibly interesting harris
you know as a press secretary and as a
president presumably i assume the
president pays attention to the news
anytime you have a big event like this
which certainly there's been a lot of
build up this is only the second solo
press conference for president biden in
the white house you wake up and you
survey the headlines and joe just walked
us through some of the crises but the
problem for this administration is when
the media starts to notice look at the
headlines president biden and jin saki
woke up to gallup biden year one
approval rating subpar extremely
polarized the hill biden hits one year
mark in dire straits the washington post
the long slide inside biden's declining
popularity as he struggles with multiple
crises and politico saying this poll
numbers are under water his agenda is
stalled and fellation is soaring covet
19 is raging and the midterms are coming
that as a press secretary and a
president are not the headlines you want
to wake up to the real question here is
whether the media harris will stand up
and ask the questions there are four
journalists in that room i know to be
good journalists
among them are peter ducey of course
philip wegman a great journalist steve
nelson james rose and there are some
good reporters in there but will they be
called on will they be called on or will
jen saki give joe biden the list of of
people to question him who's those four
names are missing i know those
journalists would hold him accountable
can i ask you a quick follow-up though
kaylee and and you're going to take it
away from here
but i'm curious did you ever pass out or
were you given a i mean did you know
exactly who was going to ask what in the
room like you had your four favorites so
you knew who would be fair
and i totally get that yeah but i mean
i've been in those instances with you
and interviewed the president i don't
ever remember
having that kind of information giving
to your team
but that's what we've seen and i mean
when when jinsaki says well it depends
on what you ask if the president's going
to take your questions well that tells
me is he getting the questions in
advance look it's a fair question
yeah it is a fair question if they're
getting questions in advance you know
reporters weren't giving me questions
for president trump in advance maybe one
or two reporters would say hey i'm
interested in this like this is what i
want to ask the president heads up
because they want to get their question
answered but no i didn't have a list of
every question i knew the reporters in
the room and i'd say hey mr president
maybe don't call on this reporter today
they seem a little hot but i'll tell you
this president trump if i told him not
to call him he would do it he was the
first reporter he caught on
exactly
exactly um
emily i i wanted you to take a look at
these numbers you know when you look at
those solo news conferences in the white
house bush had four obama had five trump
had one a conference in the white house
uh biden so far won but when you look at
the numbers of you know press
conferences with foreign leaders and
whatnot biden has done far fewer than
his predecessors and it only comes by
the way after the white house
correspondent correspondents association
president called him out steve portnoy
with very strong words saying this
eisenhower who championed democracy
versus totalitarianism and communism
built the interstates and sent troops to
integrate schools made a point of
holding news conferences two times a
month the historical record of a
presidency requires more than fleeting q
and a he said that on january 9th and
then we get this announcement of a press
conference a few days later so my point
is it only came after really begging
from the press and the president of waka
that we even got this press conference
right and and i think his point is
important to underline
we have we have a facsimile of a
president there in the white house we
have a shell a vessel someone who is
occupying that position that certainly
has in no way communicated any type of
dedication to the american public
certainly not in the realm of
communication and transparency which by
the way are pretty much the only two
things we have to go on right other than
leadership which clearly is missing too
kaylee i'd like to also discuss
something that you just touched on so
when when a
reporter would would say to you hey
we're interested in discussing the
southern border it was because they
wanted to ensure that you could bring
all of the information it was for the
purpose of ensuring that they were as
educated as possible to ensure the
highest volume of information transfer
possible here however with this white
house the the asking of the questions
knowing in advance knowing who and what
to call on is because of the spin and
that media spin is what we continue to
enjoy as an american public including
just this week when joe lockhart on cnn
just on sunday complained that the press
is is treating biden unfairly he said
with the same snark he said that yes
trump deserved his words but not this
president and then he said he literally
said there ought to have been a dividend
for quote restoring truth and decency to
the white house i can't believe that the
press is treating this president with
this same snark if this is what he deems
unfair i have no idea
what treating this president with
curtis courteous criticism what that
would do to his charts and then he went
on to say that gensake is blessing us
with the truth every day he said and yet
we don't see her on air he said
therefore ensuring that media was about
entertainment and not information
transfer but last time i checked this
network has her every time she carries a
live press conference so at least here
we're committed to facts the truth and
transparency however the white house
seems to not be
right and dagon it's my view that the
press should reflect in some way the
mood of the people and look when this
first press conference happened with
president biden he was very popular
immigration was his really one crisis at
that point this is a different mood the
american people have said we've had
enough of joe biden 33 approval
quinnipiac a pull out today from
politico that a majority disagree that
biden is energetic a strong leader a
clear communicator keeps his promises
and is capable of leading the country
when this is how the american people
feel it is incumbent on a press to ask
tough questions do you think we will get
that
yes because they're narcissists and the
narcissism trumps the being a sycophant
to a president who is this profoundly
unpopular it would be a bad look if the
press bow down and geniflect in front of
this president and don't ask hard
questions and to that note there are two
things the substance of this that will
be important and then also the
performance the substance is just ask
the president
this is
a bad year who are you going to fire
should ron claim go he clearly vetted
that speech that you gave down in
georgia and even dick durbin not not so
suddenly said that it went a little too
far and i was surprised that dick durbin
knew even where that line was or is it
one of many cabinet secretaries who need
to hit the beach so to speak i can go
through a list but becerra health and
human services disaster on covid
mallorcas on the border cardonas
targeting parents failing children on
education or jennifer granholm who
didn't even know how much oil the united
states consumed when talking about the
strategic petroleum reserve oil prices
at a seven year high on the performance
watch by to see if he's cogent to see if
he has biden mo abide moment or moment
if he makes sense does he lose his train
of thought does joe biden today have
that kind of moment where if he was your
grandfather you get the family together
and talk about taking his car keys away
right
exactly right well look we don't take
every white house briefing but we will
certainly like yesterday we didn't but
we will certainly be taking president
biden's briefing today and make sure to
tune in to fox news live coverage of
president biden's second solo white
house news conference you will not want
to miss it our coverage kicks off at 4
pm eastern time with martha mccallum hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now